hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
continuing our coverage of the 1971
candid dis tournament between Petrosian
and bobby fischer Petrosian the heavy
favorite in this tournament up into this
point in game number six both sides are
tied from points Bobby Fischer came out
won Game one
Petrosian won Game two and there's been
three drawls since then now Petrosian
does have the white pieces in game
number six who's gonna be looking to
take the advantage going into game
number seven he starts out with Knight
to f3 we don't see too much of the ready
opening but that is what we have here c5
pawn to b3 d5 Bishop to b2 and then f6
which may look like an interesting move
since most people are gonna recommend
not playing f6 myself included this is
one of those rare openings where you
will see f6 white is not trying to
control the center of the board with his
pawns right now and so Bobby Fischer
says I'm gonna do everything I can in my
power to control with the pawns you can
start to see with the c5 d5 now f6 is
gonna prepare the way for e5 without
needing the knight so many times the
knight will come to c6 you could get
your Bishop involved into the game to
protect this pond but he wants to push
forward with E 5 even before he gets his
knight too involved into the game so
this is that rare case we're gonna see
that f6 but this does weaken the Kings
side of the board it also does not allow
Bobby Fischer in the future to play
Knight to f6 which is a pretty common
move for black early on especially if
you're gonna be castling on the King
side so Bobby Fischer needs to really
put a lot of pressure push his pawns as
far down Whiteside the board as you can
and really try to just strangle and keep
white from really developing his board
if Petrosian can develop his board state
he's gonna have a better in game just as
far as the the pawn structure as far as
the weakened king side the board from
Bobby Fischer just need to make sure he
can develop his pieces get everything
involved into the action we see a c4 and
then d4 exactly what Bobby Fischer's
looking to do here stop a lot of the
squares that
yt control this dark square bishop here
on b2 is not doing anything being
blocked off from the pond here on a d4
pond d3 does allow if the bishop ever
wants to come down to see one can swing
over to the king side of the board here
but all in all this really just blocks
off these light square bishop so maybe
eventually the lights her bishop can
come here to g2 but all in all bobby
fisher' doing exactly what he wants to
do cuz after E 5 you can see he just has
a lot more pressure on this center of
the board now if we come back and say
what other options did Petrosian have
here he didn't have to push with his
pawn here he could have played something
like c3 Knight to c3 that is attacking
the pawn
maybe now the pawn comes down to d4
attacking the knight Knight to e4
we could see pawn down here to e5 same
moves from Bobby Fischer one slight
differences now we see III instead of
having moved either the C or the D pawn
now this is immediately threatening this
center of the board from Bobby Fischer
his dark square bishop here is attacking
the center of the board he can get his
light square bishop involved to the
board very easily and he has two knights
that are very active in the board you
can see how different that is then if we
come back and see after E 5 here this
lights our Bishop cannot get involved
into the game this dark square Bishop is
not doing too much this night is on b1
it's not very active so slight
difference I think
Petrosian could have taken and not
played that c4 move early on but in the
game that's exactly what happened now he
plays III this does start to attack this
the center of the board from Bobby
Fischer also opens up for his lights for
Bishop to come here to e2 and castle on
the King side whenever he's ready to do
that Bobby Fischer continues with Knight
to e7 I think Knight to c6 is fine as
well putting another defender on at the
square he already has two pawns in his
queen but a pretty common development
move from black here decided to play
Knight to e7 Bishop to e2 Knight to c6
so really wants to get this Knight
out of the way for the dark square
bishop to get involved into the action
but doesn't want to move his night here
on b8 which is a little surprising
because he could have just come here to
see six in the first place but Knight to
d2 here Bishop e7 castle on the Kings
side and castle on the Kings side as
well and then pawn to e4 so Petrosian
seems to be okay solidifying the pawn
chain right here knowing that Bobby
Fischer definitely has a lot more
pressure since his pawn has come down to
this fourth rank that's when you can
tell you're in your opponent's territory
you can see Patterson does not have that
also as a backward pawn here on the
three that Bobby Fischer eventually if
he can get past these enemy lines here
can start to attack here now we have a
six-night back here to e1 recognizing
there's not much going on on the Kings
side the board very difficult to get a
lot of action here this pawn on f6 does
stop a lot of the threats as far as the
squares that white would want to go to
this LightSquared bishop is also
stopping a lot of the squares that white
might go to as well so matures and looks
at this and says I'm gonna bring my
knight back here to e1 maybe get
involved on the Queen side of the board
which is exactly where Bobby Fischer
looks to be aiming his pieces plays pawn
to b5 just trying to blow up this Queen
side of the board as well Bishop to g4
says he I'll go in exchange material
right here and then Queen to c7 or
excuse me Queen to ca which I thought
was interesting for Bobby Fischer saying
yeah I'm gonna go ahead and give up my
Queen if you want to feeling that
confident in his pawn structure in the
setup that he has petrosian's having
none of it brings the Queen back here to
e2 and the Knight to d7 and I'd here to
see to rook to b8 just putting pressure
on this B file looking to eventually
exchange here rook over here to a c1
Queen e8 a bishop here to a3 wasn't
doing anything hon b2 we saw that it was
blocked off and this is just saying okay
this this pawn is a little less defended
than this pawn here on d4 so decided to
go ahead and bring it here to start to
attack that Bishop to b6 opening up for
the Queen to just control the square
here on e5 Knight back here to eat one
just
couldn't find any ground for it to go to
be conceived from Bobby Fischer
standpoint his pawns are doing a good
job of blocking off so many of these
squares that white really wants to go to
then we have g6 so something even more
squares that white could go to it's
really difficult to figure out how why
it's gonna continue as far as Hilda his
development plan does decide to go ahead
and take here on b5 I would see the
exchange back then the bishop comes back
here to be to Knight to b6 here not up
here to f3 rook to e8 so we do have a
semi open file the rook here on c1 for
whites attacking this but then from
Bobby Fischer standpoint he is attacking
the a file here as well with his rook a3
and then we have the knight coming here
to a5 attacking this pawn you always
want to look at the material that's left
behind this pawn is defending this pawn
here on b3 as soon as it moved Bobby
Fischer melee brings his knight here to
a5 attacking this pawn here on b3 which
currently is only defended by the knight
on D - so Petrosian brings his queen
back here to d2 does not want to have
his knights here on D - hanging out
wants to be able to develop it as needed
so he has to have a piece come back and
defend this pawn here on b3 now we have
Queen to f7 and this is preparing for
pawn c4 you can see this night this
nights right here all of those pieces
eyeing up on this c4 square very
important so the Queen comes down here
to f7 to prepare for that push as well
we have a fourth to stop of the
immediate push so pawn takes here
Pommery captures here on a4 now white
does have a passed pawn gonna be looking
to push that as much as possible and
then see for the push that we talked
about and then after the take right here
we do see have the pawn here on the for
this is a passed pawn that Bobby Fischer
is also going to be looking to push as
much as possible Knight takes we do see
in exchange in the center of the board
and then Queen to e2
Knight takes here on a b2 so quite a bit
of material coming off the board Queen
takes on a b2
rook to b8 forcing the Queen to move
comes to a - really forcing a Bobby
Fischer to make a decision ears if he
wants to go ahead take with this Queen
he's gonna have to do something because
he can't move his Queen because it's
being pinned down by this Queen to his
king here decides to go ahead and do an
in-between move of Bishop to b4 and then
the Queen takes in the King recaptures
right here rook comes up here to c7
check and the King comes to e6 now and
the game Petrosian decides to play g4 he
did have the option if he wanted to take
with his rook here on h7 he takes this
pawn but blacks gonna be able to get
that pawn back he could play Bishop to
c3 and you can't just play rook they to
trying to hold on to this material you
can see the rook is attacking the pawn
here on e4 can't do that because rook
down here to be one this would
eventually be checkmate this is a back
rank make Raik mate there's no way for
white to stop this he could play Knight
to II want to drag it out one more move
but you can see there's no place for
this came to go so instead the rooks not
gonna come to a two that would be a
terrible move he could play rook to c1
attacking the bishop getting out of
harm's way but you can see this is a
nice little outpost that Bobby Fischer
has but then the rook can just come down
taking on a four so Petrosian knowing he
can't take that material freely decides
a different path decides instead to go
pawn to g4 now you could see after rook
or excuse me Bishop to c3 it's
completely fine if the rook were to come
up to a - not necessarily saying that
he's going to but now if the rook were
to come down to b1 then the King can
come to g2 freely it's not gonna be that
back ranked mates pretty difficult to
say if he tried over and over again so
after the bishop does come back to a c3
then we are going to see rook to a2 rook
to c8 and then we do have an exchange
right here but that just frees up the
chosen to start
pushing his pawn up the board here rook
to a8 but that's not stopping Petrosian
pawn to a6 rook to a7 says yeah I don't
want you to push that any further up the
board here so it does play rook to a
seven and then King to f1 trying to get
that involved into the action pawn to g5
on the Kings side of the board King to
e2 King here to a d6 now if you look at
both sides stands that Black has a
better position
yes White has a passed pawn but so does
black here on d4 but this bishops gonna
be able to cover more ground knowing
that there's a pawn over here on the
Queen side as well as pawn structures
over here on at the King side as well
the bishop just does a better job of
controlling more of the board state
where the knight it does better if
there's just pawns on one side of the
board it can really focus on attacking a
lot of the critical squares but right
now this bishops gonna be able to fly
around especially with rooks on the
board it just just better fighting
alongside a rook so then the King's
gonna come to d3 King to a c5 here you
can see the work that this outpost on d4
is doing here for black now back here to
do one trying to find a good square that
the knight can go to has to come back to
d1 before can come here to e2 here King
b5 and then Knights here to e2 and this
is the next move it I think is just
shows the brilliance and Bobby Fischer
because I think so many people are gonna
see this and say okay the king is here
the rook can freely take here it's gonna
go up a pawn and material this is why
the King has come over here but it
actually doesn't work quite like that
after the rook takes then the rook can
take here on a six the King takes but
then the knight takes and you can see
now that although is an outpost then
this King's gonna take here and this is
gonna be a drawing game there's no way
for either side to advance past and
actually do any damage here so if we
come back here Bobby Fischer looks at
this and says yeah I'm not gonna take
with my rook here instead I'm gonna play
Bishop to a5 now how does white really
continue from here he decided
go ahead and check with this rook here
on b2 but the king can freely take on a6
and that is such a brilliant move
because I think it is very difficult to
find to set this up so that your rook
stops it your Bishop defends it and then
your King can go ahead and take it here
on a six so now we have the rook come
back here to be one Rick to c7 rook to
b1 or b2 Bishop down here to e1
attacking this pawn on f2 pawn comes up
here to f3 King a5 rook c2 says yeah if
you want to exchange we definitely can
here Bobby Fischer not looking to do
that wants to be using his rook on the
board yes he has a pawn advantage but he
also recognizes that his opponent right
now has central control his King over
here on a5 it's not really in the place
that he wants it to be so has to get
that in a better position if he ever
wants to exchange these rooks on the
board rook to a to check King comes back
we do see another check now the bishop
comes in and defends the King a little
bit with Bishop to b4 rook a to Rick a
c7 controlling the file again rook to a1
you can see both sides just moving back
and forth not really doing any damage
here we do see the rook come down here
to d5 outpost move checking the King
here but pretty easy to stop that with
Bishop here to c5 King comes back here
to a4 then rook to d7 always attacking
this pawn but as soon as he takes it you
can you just get a sense that he's just
no longer involved into the game here
Bishop to b4 and then Knight to e2 King
down to b3 rook to b7 says yeah I want
to stop the bishop for moving here
that's completely fine can get the rook
involved to the into the game with rook
to a8 here and then the rook takes on h7
again what really happens here he could
try something like Knight takes here on
d4 yes he is giving up a knight here for
a pawn here but then he could take his
pawn here on h7 he does get two pawns in
exchange
for vast nights and could just try to
make something of this it's just very
difficult to see exactly how why it's
gonna continue but he decides to take
with his rook here on h7
but then work down to a one-man it's so
tough to stop the rook to d1 cuz you can
see that's checkmate there's just no
good way for white to get out of this
his rook is completely out of the game
now so it is up to this knight to stop
this decides now he has to now take
material on d4 or he's just gonna lose
the game or give up his knife for
nothing
so the pond takes the King takes here's
who gives up his Knights for two pawns
but then rook to d1 King comes back here
to e3 you can see after a few moves it's
just so difficult to hold on to the game
here so after a few more moves
eventually we do see Petrosian decide to
go ahead and resign in this position
it's just no way to stop it the bishops
doing a good job of stopping some of the
moves the white King can come to rook to
h1 eventually would be checkmate so
Petrosian decides although I had the
white pieces and it's definitely not
what I wanted I need to resign to Bobby
Fischer in game number 6 so Bobby
Fischer has got to be feeling pretty
good going into games number 7 he'll
have the white pieces and also a game
lead you can start to see momentum
shifting into a Bobby Fischer's favor
but that is game number 6 of 1971 at
Canada's tournament hopefully you guys
enjoyed and I'll see you guys next time
in game number 7